don't wait for someone to teach you the
language the language is there hi steve
kaufman here again and today i want to
talk about
the most important qualities of a
successful language learner if you enjoy
these videos please subscribe click on
the bell for notifications
and if you follow me on a podcast
service please leave a review
so
what what makes a successful language
learner
now there are a lot of you know
objective considerations where you live
if you have access to a lot of good
content
uh there are a lot of the language that
you speak how similar is it to a
language that you're learning there are
many objective factors but there are
also important subjective factors
uh and i was thinking about this today
um
and i was thinking about it in terms of
my
continuing sort of struggles with arabic
and persian
and i don't spend as much time as i
would like
i don't think i
did any work on either one of those
languages today
but
every day every second day i do some
and it occurred to me that that the
important consideration is
that i continue doing something
i'm not expecting
a sort of dramatic improvement
as long as i'm spending time with the
language i will improve
and
you know i had a conversation yesterday
in persian after not having done
anything with the language for two weeks
and i did okay
so
and so i thought to myself you know we
have to be patient we have to be
confident
that as long as we're putting time in
with the language we're listening here
we're reading there we're doing
something we're getting some kind of an
activity score at link as long as as
we're doing those things
we are improving so it's it's important
to be
patient
uh and to be confident
that every time we're engaging with the
language we are helping to create neural
networks in our brain
that will improve our ability in the
language
if we go through periods of intensive
work with the language or in
you know significant opportunity to use
the language will improve faster but
nevertheless as long as we're putting
time in we are improving so we need to
have that sense of patience so i think
patience is an important quality another
way of looking at it
is this idea of living in the moment
when you are with the language when you
are listening or reading
just remind yourself that what you're
doing is valuable and it's going to
improve your ability in the language
if you have content that's of interest
to you so much the better you can enjoy
that
time that you're spending with the
language sometimes we have to do things
or
engage with content that's less
interesting we're reading it for the
second or third time we're listening for
the fifth time
and so maybe it's less enjoyable
but it helps if we
recognize that
all of this activity even though we
don't sense a dramatic improvement it is
improving us so patience
living in the moment these are important
characteristics
another important characteristic is
initiative
so for example in romance languages and
in fact in many languages
things like conjugations are difficult
uh if we're writing in the language
don't just write the first if it's j ki
is it with a t with an s you can't
remember don't just write it look it up
it's so easy nowadays
to
google
you know conjugate the verb
point in french or
um
no whatever hablar in espanol in spanish
google it find it look for it uh when
i'm reviewing now i'm not doing romance
languages but context reverso has a
wonderful conjugating dictionary take
the opportunity to look up the
conjugation whenever you come across a
form of that verb
uh so these are initiatives you can take
if you feel that you're lacking in
certain uh you know technical jargon or
other terminology or vocabulary items
another thing you can do which i
sometimes do
is i'll write something up in english
use google translate to convert it into
whatever language i'm learning and
what i wrote in english contained the
vocabulary items that i was interested
in and lo and behold i will now see
those in the target language i can
import that
into link and study it so that's another
example of taking the initiative
don't wait for someone to teach you the
language the language is there there are
so many different ways that you can
acquire bits and pieces of information
about the language speaking of
initiative i recently bought a scanning
pen
because i have these arabic textbooks so
i've i now can scan a line in the
textbook
and if i have
an app open on my computer which could
be you know google drive it could be or
google documents it could be anything
including the import page at link
then that sentence will appear
if it's arabic or persian or whatever
french spanish whatever you're studying
that sentence will appear in the text
space
in the import
section of link so that's just an
initiative not everyone is going to run
out and buy a scanning pen but
it's just a matter of you know taking
charge of your learning is so important
in so many different ways choosing the
content you're interested in
uh
taking initiatives so
to summarize here again it's it's being
patient so to some extent these things
are a bit contradictory you have to be
patient you have to enjoy the moment
live in the moment
however you also have to take initiative
you have to take initiative
in terms of
okay today i'm going to study or i'm
interested in this subject or i'm going
to go to netflix or i'm going to look up
the conjugation table or i'm going to
look up declension tables for russian
nouns you got to take the initiative you
can't wait for someone to teach you the
declension so i think that those are
some of the important
characteristics and finally
another important character
characteristic i think is to accept
uncertainty and i've mentioned this
before
uh
you know you're not going to understand
everything you're going to forget things
uh even after a long time it seems that
you don't understand the same
bits and pieces that you're listening to
but
accept the uncertainty and so this ties
back to the other two characteristics so
if you're a bit confused about the
declension or the conjugation look it up
i
accept the uncertainty be patient
enjoy the moment enjoy the time you're
spending with the language so i'd like
to leave you with two videos one that i
did a year ago and one that i did seven
years ago and they talk about the one
seven years ago talked about learning in
the moment and the one that i did a year
ago talked about learning languages in
the moment i haven't looked at them i
didn't look at them in preparation for
this video
perhaps i was of a different opinion a
year ago or seven years ago at any rate
if you're interested you can go and have
a look thank you for listening bye for
now